who is Luffy's Mom after 25 years the  identity of Luffy's mother still hasn't  been revealed there is no confirmation  that she is dead so she could be out  there somewhere and this has led a ton  of fans to speculate about her true  identity popular candidates for Luffy's  mom include Bello Betty and jewelry  Bonnie due to their connection to the  revolutionaries and Luffy's father  Dragon but in reality they are both too  young to be Luffy's mom one of my  favorite theories is that Luffy's mother  is a Celestial Dragon and that she had a  forbidden affair with Luffy's Dad after  she gave birth to Luffy she was  imprisoned by the world Nobles and she  could still be in captivity to this day  wanting to rescue her may be one of the  reasons why Dragon declared war on the  world Nobles in the first place  subscribe right now for more anime  Mysteries like